-Our first guest tonight
is an Academy Award-nominated
and Emmy-winning actor who you
know from shows like "Cheers"
and "True Detective" and films
such as "White Men Can't Jump,"
and "Zombieland,"
and "Triangle of Sadness."
He stars in "Champions," which
opens in theaters March 10th.
Let's take a look.
-My name is Marcus Marakovich
and I am going to be
your basketball coach
for the next three months.
-Nope.
-[ Laughs ]
-Wait. What?
-I said nope.
[ Basketball dribbling ]
-Is this something
he normally does?
-Nope.
-That's Darius.
He's our best player.
I'm Johnny. I'm your homie
with an extra chromie.
-Whoa.
-Please welcome back to
the show, our friend,
Woody Harrelson, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Listen, I know you guys
are here to see Niall,
but I appreciate that.
-Very nice of them.
Very nice of them.
How do you think I -
-I'm happy to see Niall, too.
-Yeah.
-Like, I saw him backstage.
I was, like, fawning like
a little school girl. Any way.
-That's very nice that
you can be honest about that.
-Yeah.
-I felt the same way.
I saw Niall backstage
and I had the same reaction.
-But yeah, my - my daughter,
Mac, is, like, a huge fan.
And so, you know,
she woke us up the other night
when he dropped his single.
-Dude.
-It woke us up.
[ Laughter ]
Like - we're like -
[ Cheers and applause ]
-At what time can you wake up
Woody Harrelson?
Like, what - what's a good time?
-I don't think it's ever
a good idea.
-Yeah.
-You know?
-Let a sleeping Woody lie?
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-Now you - I should stress,
you needed a little sleep
because you did one of the great
late night endeavors.
Last Saturday, you hosted "SNL"
for your fifth time.
-Yeah.
-Fantastic episode.
-Yeah, that was -
that was exciting.
-And I - let me say,
the five-Timers club --
the real accomplishment,
you didn't just knock out
five hosting stints
in seven years.
You stretched this out.
-Yeah.
-It speaks to the breadth
of your career.
Your first one was 1989.
Do you remember your first time
hosting "SNL"?
-Not even a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, hold - let me reframe it.
Do you remember much
about last Saturday?
-Nothing. Nothing at all.
That's -- even then, I didn't --
I know that I left after --
-Yeah.
-After, at 6:00.
-So, that's where my memory
started.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Amazing.
-But is it - do you remember -
the high of hosting?
Does that feel the same,
even though you're doing it
for your fifth time?
-Oh, there was a serious high
of hosting going on.
-I walked -- [ Laughs ]
-I promise I'm not trying
to walk right into this.
-Everyone in the dressing room
had a whole high of hosting.
-So, you're saying
it's almost contagious
when they're around you.
-It was contagious.
-Yeah.
Thick with -- anyway.
-Hey, this is very exciting.
So, you have your own --
your own weed dispensary?
-I do.
-Congratulations.
-Yeah, yeah.
-The Woods?
-The Woods.
-And this is an L.A. billboard,
and this is an old photo of you.
-Yeah.
-Now, I was thinking, like,
what do you think this young man
would think if you told him
in the future,
you're going to own
a legal marijuana dispensary?
-Well, at the time,
he didn't smoke.
-Really?
-So, he would have been like,
"No way."
I was very religious
at that time.
This is -- I was working as
a lifeguard at a --
anyway, someone sent this to --
it was at a church camp.
I didn't want to get into
all that.
But okay.
So, I used to go to church.
Anyway, yeah.
So, someone sent that to
The Woods.
-Yeah.
-And then we were like,
"Well, let's just use this."
-Yeah.
I will say, yeah -- I mean,
I would have definitely guessed
"weed" before
"church camp lifeguard."
[ Laughter ]
Based on the photo.
Well, that's very exciting.
Have you enjoyed it?
I mean, it must be a nice moment
to be able to --
I mean, this is something you've
been a fan of for a while.
-Well, it's really
the most beautiful place
you've ever seen.
I mean,
it is stunningly beautiful.
Thomas Schoos, who is a partner,
did the designing,
and he's, like --
he's a brilliant designer.
So, it's, like --
it's beautiful.
It's the most beautiful
dispensary in the world.
After that,
I can't promise anything.
But there is - there's
a ganja giggle garden out back
where you can go out there
and, um, giggle.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a giggle garden.
This was amazing.
Somebody -- in our lives, every
now and then, we might encounter
who we or other people will say
is your doppelganger.
Right? You lay eyes on them
and you go, "Oh, my God,
I can't believe I lived my whole
life and there's a person
on earth who looks
just like me."
-I can't wait to see this.
-Well, this is --
somebody posted this on Twitter.
You responded to it.
Their daughter --
their infant daughter.
-Oh, yes, yes.
-Yeah.
-And I was like, "How can an
infant daughter look like
Woody Harrelson?"
-Spitting image.
-I mean, that's insane.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What a trip.
-Yeah.
I mean, can you imagine
how messed up
she's going to be in life?
[ Laughter ]
Later, people are showing her
this picture.
[ Laughter ]
-I think she'll be --
I think she's gonna --
They say all babies grow out
of their Woody phase, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I've got a lot more questions,
including about the film.
We'll be right back with more
from Woody Harrelson.